le constat meilleur ou le pire laisse
moi je dis
même si demain ces quatre ans
entre
[Musique]
c'est magnifique on est passé de 1 0 1
60e minute lyon était un pape organisé
et puis elle m'a fait entrer en mêlée
qui leur soutien me relève patrick camus
un président qui fait sur moi non
alice au pays des merveilles au pays des
merveilles pour cette cause est osé
[Musique]
salah excusez moi ça c'est michael
jackson sur san jose et moi ça c'est
michael jackson ça c'est michael jackson
[Musique]
est mort
m
[Musique]
kim
millions
je ne peux pas m on a vu tellement
d'émotion et je n'ai pas le temps petit
hic
ouais j'aime maquilleuse
il m'a volé ma culotte et maple je veux
mes articles je m'appelle
monsieur le chef ou tout maquillage nude
et moi un peu de ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]